dinky dink dink
welcome back here under the jaw and
Jillian podcast that's right I'm over to
get my younger brother Marlon ah he is
our guest this week on podcast peeps
last week we asked you if you care to
see a Channing ginger on the podcast and
you said you wanted him so we wanted to
do that for you so here he is welcome
our guest Thank You Nina
is so I don't I don't know why we're
almost 100 episodes deep and you haven't
been on here but you're on now I guess
that's all that matters right mm-hmm
are you excited I'm very excited we
asked him here like hey Marge they want
to be on the podcast and he was like
yeah but can I ask you questions okay
cool dude good so this is also our first
green-screen guest oh wow didn't and
mom's gonna choose the backup so
whatever it is it's his fault you're
welcome this episode is brought to you
by meat undies guys get the most
comfortable underwear out there made of
micro modal fabric twice the softest
cotton and with the dopest designs like
this ah get it on your butt go to Mia
nice calm slash Jenna Julian get 20% off
your first purchase also brought to you
by a new sponsor this week BPI sports
guys this is a sports supplement company
for those of you who get your Fitness on
which I know a lot of you do they have
some amazing products a whole line of
stuff right here we have just a couple
I'll talk about them later they have
branch chains amino acids pre-workout
amazing whey protein go to BPI sports
com2 check out their selection and uh
I'm going to talk about this stuff later
so you will hear more about that thank
you to our sponsors thank you sponsors
I've actually tried that stuff it's good
right yeah do just lip and stealing my
roommates wow that's a good roommate so
College saris happy was sorry exactly
alright so remain same as zappy you met
him what but he didn't introduce himself
as a person
nice guys [ __ ] parents given name I
would have been better though his
parents birth the child and we're like
it's a boy happy happy the beans a P so
the dogs are in the room as well as you
guys can tell if you're watching not
listening but if you're listening there
are no dogs in the room mmm ringing at
Birth speech I don't know she's walking
around she's just gonna page thing she's
doing peach things so all right Marlon
ah for those who don't know my own is my
hair brother he's going to be 21 soon oh
he's currently attending Chapman
University and you're studying
psychology hmm what is that like we have
two psychology almost majors here it's
very interesting I study sociology as
well yeah so it's kind of different
viewpoints yeah yeah I mean anyone that
tells you that study psychology will
tell you it's it's pretty fascinating
how little we know about who we are
yeah and yeah it's just very eye-opening
everything we learn and when you come
over you get to talk to Jenna and have
intelligent conversations which I still
can't do so I cannot oh my god Rachel um
and you are a junior here one more year
left mm-hmm
and you're gonna adopt Kermit mm-hmm
okay we're gonna ride it I think I've
met very very very few people who are
the dogs all three collectively like
more than Marlin Marlin is our dog
center of choice he's number one draft
pick but he's always at school number
one draft pick what was your signing
bonus three dogs
yes all right so I guess before we start
pounding you this question
yeah Marlon you have questions for us
question oh my I'm like so nervous by
the way what I by Lee he knows the fan
fiction he saw it he's son yeah he saw
because someone posted on Instagram I
was [ __ ] dying I was like short of
just skimming through that first chapter
see if you wanted to read it and I just
see if the bottom Marlon is a hacker and
I'm like done four different reading
Marland is a [ __ ] hacker it was great
it was a great story yeah they know me
well yeah um all right Jenna Oh God
you have almost two billion views on
YouTube several TV and movie appearances
yeah
countless hairstyles mmm sure and even a
wax figure made after you yes what's
your favorite color
oh my god Marley the visceral level is
already at a 10 like if you guys can't
tell he has the troll Gina so I think it
might be I like I really like purple and
I really like green okay I'm probably
purple purple spring fun what about me
so you're saying that all that applies
to me and then also what color for me
blue look given that she has a wax
figure if she'd never wax figure be red
we have temperatures rising ice melting
and the populations that you see he was
released 37 billion metric tons of co2
every year and 58,000 square miles of
forest our commotions
Julian what's your favorite movie that's
good question well we're into he's such
a jewel be good Big Daddy was very Danny
let you Jenna mmm
it's like a tie though between the lives
and the best friend's wedding so there's
no one that was sort of yet or airplane
or the jerk
yeah the jerk up there see one Sam so
this is the 21st century in the dirt and
we have a presidential candidate with to
eliminate an entire religion we as a
society still stigmatized and
stereotyped and discriminate against the
minority whether the race religion
gender identity mental disorder sexual
orientation whether it be consciously or
unconsciously this in my eyes is the
biggest social problem but I got to know
how do you guys stay so fit Jonna ah I
don't I love I mean whatever kidding me
I like try my best but
million is the one that's like jiu-jitsu
all the time and Julian works out a lot
yeah but the only reason I've I ever get
to see myself look fit is because I'm
have my diet I'll down which is what
Jenna helps me with but a lot of
vegetables and um yeah a lot of
vegetables I'd say that's probably my
number one tip mm-hmm
working out school but if you can eat
your diet right guys you'll get fat and
if Andy's BPI sports nutrition you will
get fit and it's good for the
environment too that is unless meat and
oh yeah very good vegetables got a
cheaper to watch they're cheaper than
you really thick wait how do you say
something you're like everyone calls me
the ginger Channing Tatum okay first of
all why don't you respond to that little
allegation is so deadlift doll mom and
dad love doll Marlon Kenda Marlon was
deadlifting mid 400s before he hurt his
back here his back a little bit why is
that a good thing okay so it wasn't
Channing Tatum named like the sexiest
man alive into 2014 or something yeah oh
I was thinking about someone completely
different you know you didn't know when
they were calling me Channing Channing
Tatum was I I have no idea wait who was
in your brain like describe them well he
was like 400 pounds are you serious what
he's just [ __ ] afraid
all right last question kids in school
are being bullied big corporations pair
of government to act as puppets and
global warming is clear no one's doing
anything about it
nothing hmm what's your favorite drink
at Starbucks not oh my god Marlon okay
um I have been drinking a lot of lattes
with the coconut milk or soy milk and
sugar-free vanilla syrup it's really
gwad I like it a lot yeah they're really
good water God about you I mean given
the thing you said about the economy
definitely a cat chance mm-hmm I like
the phone and the coffee it's like it
takes away the weight of the milk it's
like it's like the only consistent dairy
I'm so consuming is like the cabbage
no this one okay no yeah let it come up
that's high PG um okay that she loves me
a little more that is true um
so Jimmy questions for Marlon what
should we what should we have I asked
him right now um Marlon I don't have you
know every time you're in a vlog and as
pretty smitten with you okay I have a
question on behalf of the Internet are
you single
was that you
what is my son he's still laying in
front of the mic he's like don't tell
them are you available no no no no
there's no maybes on Jones I'm very
single okay yeah he's painfully single
guys jolly brutally single ladies he's
brutally sick maybe maybe you should buy
some Mia knees and just walk around me
and wait a minute you have a none dear
on coming up oh yeah you need awareness
of me a decently undies we'll get you
some me at ease for nandi right Chapman
University to do that I'm in a run where
they just run around in their underwear
yeah like a bunch of [ __ ] animals
have loved it I didn't love it I did
like twice out of my entire time there
you guys should come this year
hell no no thanks we'll give you me and
ease to run sweet oh my god I just can't
get over those trolli questions but what
questions do you have for Marlon Marlon
your brother questions did you think I
was gonna ask when I that bad about that
was about what I thought yeah you know
something along those lines since what I
was expecting
preparing um so what I mean this is a
question you probably get all the time
but I'm sure there's a lot of
college-age kids out there what do you
want to do when you're done with college
or what do you see yourself in a year
and a half doing with your life
or at least trying to do with your life
don't don't no no what is that it's a
heads it it's criminal it's got a little
bit on this well five years from now I
don't know if I'm material but I want I
want I want to know like seriously what
you're thinking about leave a dog
because
like I mean we talked about a lot we've
had a whole podcast dedicated to being
in college being in school and what
you're what you're told but like having
being in this situation right now
everyone's telling you you need to
figure out your [ __ ] get your [ __ ]
together sometimes you don't need your
[ __ ] together like what are your
thoughts Oh like where are you you know
where does your where's your mind going
to be wanting to do when you're winning
out of school do you want to do more
schooling you want to that's a good
question
it's hard to answer right now yes that's
good I'm still right in the middle of it
but yeah I'm definitely waiting for a
class to really just take my interest
and I've had a few classes that I really
like psychology classes but nothing yet
that's just like for sure you know I try
getting in sports like this semester but
is full yeah some hard class to get into
just why I never got to take one before
I went to graduate school now who's
laughing well I mean you have to be
exposed to it you have to read about it
I understand if you would like to pursue
that you don't have to take it class
before you know if you'd like it or not
but Marlon was an athlete Marlon played
baseball what else did you do for sports
pretty much just baseball
um oops just connect to Minnesota yeah
I'm gonna fix it here I got it you can
keep talking but I can't hear all right
then stop talking okay
yeah Marlon play baseball like as home
as I could yeah yeah his whole life like
me we were your baseball family I guess
yeah but a little jiu-jitsu a little bit
yeah um yeah baseball really I mean just
psychology and in general because you go
up to the plate and you're like thinking
a million things in your head and
athletes just drive themselves crazy and
everyone does you know we have so many
expectations for our supposed to actor
what we think we're supposed to do but
usually what we're supposed to do is
like contradicting each other what
everyone says you're supposed to do so
it's kind of interesting yeah you know
what's funny like having been an athlete
when I watch things on TV or really kind
of big events Olympics you know one
serious stuff like that and I'm like
like I'm watching really kind of keenly
looking at their like eyes and where
their brains that like it's crazy to
think like the how focused a person
needs to be and zone out like so much
especially at that level like Jenna
played sports at a high level you know
you and I played sports high school we
you know we compete okay but like that
times a billion the whole world is
watching like literally the entire world
is watching you and you know it mm-hmm
and then you still are able to like zone
it out and kind of not only just do your
job but like be amazing at it you know
yeah that's pretty nuts yeah it's very
well we more than any other animal have
massive frontal lobe which pretty much
as you know just does nothing it just
it's like drives us crazy it's all for
thinking yeah and all we do is just lead
to like the overthink it's just massive
and monkeys have every other animal is a
tiny tiny frontal lobe especially dogs
that's why they're always so happy and
that's why you so primal you just want
like three things in life the
differences your bear and water we
forget though that were just animals
yeah you know yeah we always distinguish
animals and humans but for the same with
the same intervals speaking of animals
this shirt guys this is official podcast
votes that you can now buy we have we
launched all other line of shirts with
Sarah Matt and Paige and my pal all the
dogs on the shirts with these designs
because you guys have been asking for
these designs for a while so we finally
got them up on our storage and Julian
podcast.com and go to the merch tab to
find it I just wanted to throw that in
there because there's nothing um I want
to hear something I want to hear like
you guys tell a story that's good memory
about each other when you're not so we
should definitely do I was actually
telling Jenna about how we used to read
box and chill right yeah we used okay so
red box I don't even know if you know
what that is anymore I don't know why
you would but it's like this DVD vending
machine and there was one like a couple
blocks from our house we were growing up
and we would scooter on over there get
some [ __ ] Red Box get some snacks and
just like watch movies all night and it
was like in my mind that was like that
changed the game you'd have to go to a
blockbuster
you know you will ride on the street
and when they asked for your email you
just write John at aol.com and you don't
ever get bothered we see that you still
do down though - you still write John
AOL Commons Oh sir like Julian that's
[ __ ] up man it's easy he's got so many
what's another one email John it AOL com
is it John with an H though we're just
not Joe and at a Wow
yeah to the point however right to the
point that you said yeah um and there's
a reason why it's AOL cuz 23mm
it's the shortest easiest if it was a
Waldo it'd be easier I thought you guys
are just being like funny
because who the [ __ ] has an AOL email
address who does the Mail's well I mean
you're not wrong you're not wrong yeah
now wrong can you think of any stories
that we do him that we should tell that
we shouldn't tell me can hmm what about
the time when you were warming up in
baseball and you decide to just look
away and then you have your nose broken
by the ball that you're supposed to be
looking it was a fun story was a good
one how about I don't know if I tell us
on the podcast we were snowboarding and
we would always compete to let get high
on the jumps and Marlon like was he was
young cuz I think we were like Thursday
ages like 10 yeah so he's like watching
us get all these you know jumps were
like getting like three feet off the
ground really you [ __ ] you and I'm
taking pictures he's never jumped before
he just learned how to snowboard
basically and he comes flying down the
mountain and he goes flying off the jump
like three times the size any of us have
ever gone this completely wiped out but
my mom got this picture that looks like
he's Shaun White like literally like
five feet higher than we got and he just
like chillin in the air and he's like
it's like a perfect picture but we
always thought we're like dude you
[ __ ] ate crap right happy cuz it
doesn't matter got the pic oh my god I
was like crying my eyes out my mom's
trying to show me the picture look how
high you got she knew is a competition
didn't matter
be that you've either yeah that's really
sweet my mom sweet you know who probably
has a lot of stories but you guys is
your sister
every time I'm hanging out when your
sister has all of the stories sitting
there telling them to everybody yeah
she's a good storyteller too she is we
should have a garden I know we can have
around instead we have Marlin ah yeah we
in Milan hey we're lucky and we should
have gathered some questions for Marlin
we should do is tell stories about her
mmm dick do you have any stories about
her
yeah Joanna I used to [ __ ] with her what
would you do what why just because
you're younger then you want to [ __ ]
with your sister yeah it got a rise out
of her mmm
how much older is Roxanne the new five
years five years yeah she used to come
to my kindergarten classroom when she
was in fifth grade and like work with
the kids during lunch and stuff oh yeah
oh all right what I'm tweeting this live
we're doing this live on the podcast I'm
getting some questions all right oh I
got a question for you guys yeah what's
up when did you know that you guys were
otters oh that's really sweet
I actually remember do you remember yeah
what do you mean I remember how that
came about
oh I thought we started thought it was
like a symbolic question uh oh no it was
a time question you have to answer
symbolic and you have to answer okay so
all answer time biologically is lucemon
all right I was at work one day and a
lot of times in my old job I would kind
of get on Reddit and zone the [ __ ] out
which I think a lot of people kind of do
it
jobs but anyway I was on reddit one day
and one of the top post was like a gif
of otters and it was it was like or
maybe was it today I learned like today
I learned otters hold hands so they
don't float away from each other while I
sleep and if they don't have another
otter they grab sea kelp to stay up you
know put and I was like we had just
started dating sort of and I was like
that's adorable so I came home I was the
first thing I said I was like did you
know that otters
hands while they sleep slave away she's
like you're my otter and then that was
it yeah then we just started going to
the Rajyam
it's true right I've never felt I was
lonely in my life you have sea kelp
don't worry and then maybe some lovely
young lady after this podcast will seek
you out what's that what is this what do
you think of symbolism all symbolic
meaning fine when I thought we were
oddest we were on the beach kidding all
right so first question comes from Sonia
marks how did you come up with the plot
to Magic Mike it just was a dream and
what kind of dream like I dreamed at
night or like just one time or over and
over no just one just one time then what
happened I wake up and I read my dreams
down do you have a dream notebook mmm
[ __ ] bring it
hmm nice to do that I know you did it
makes you not lose it and I wrote the
whole script one morning yeah
and then Giselle to the studio hmm all
right next question
why you so daddy a F mm-hmm okay good
answer is the Grove Zoo opened this is a
good one Alexis writes who is Marlin
yeah I think that's a dead person okay
the most embarrassing story that you can
tell about me seriously think about this
it's not June what is the most
embarrassing story you can tell about me
that i will not absolutely wreck you
after this podcast for telling what you
go get one hi what is it thumb [ __ ] god
yuck god dammit this is gonna hurt okay
right when we started like grappling and
fighting and stuff training my brother
was a lot better than me and he knew it
so it was always him choking me out and
strangling me and stuff nice really and
I broke it yeah and this one time I
finally try to strangle him with a
triangle choke and he was so bummed that
he just got up right after and just like
elbowed the wall as hard as he could or
punched it or something and like this
huge hole in the wall and it was just
like left it there and like like like
Aragon and all right or not about that
because it was just my my trophy Rock
button wall as a trophy I totally forgot
about that so you just thought now
remember that's crazy I got up I tapped
I got up and [ __ ] put a hole in the
water Wow I just thought it wasn't me
you're like maybe a solid Marlin it
wouldn't be a trophy then at all that's
a pretty good starting mm-hmm although
I'm not super embarrassed by it what do
you have any embarrassing stories of
Marlin you don't want to get him back
right now
well I should have thought this through
before we got on here after stupid
because we want to ask him somebody to
not get embarrassed yeah you know shut
up Marlin will you marry me Nicole yeah
sure Nicole asked that this redhead
jokes you ever heard so people call you
ginger or anything like that no no wait
so do you go to like meetings to deal
with getting bullied as the ginger or
like yeah I do
you know people ask me why I'm always
like so tan for a ginger but the truth
is I'm not actually a ginger what are
you
Ginger's by definition I believe have
blue eyes and red hair and fair skin and
fair skin and I have bluish green eyes
pretty big difference oh my god your
troll um do you watch Parks and Rec yeah
just started watching it that's really
cute you guys watch it together
what's your least favorite thing about
Julian hmm-hmm-hmm his stupid face
that's that's that's easy what's the
real biggest thing I have a feeling I
know what it is oh yeah
yeah what's that no I'll let you say
wait really
yeah listen um there's a channel what
I'm sorry I was reading another quick a
forget it were you just texting Roxanne
to get a story no okay you can actually
dig in text reverse story if that's what
you're into text about why don't you do
that I'll be the sponsors if this place
excited up guys really quick I just want
to shout out to up sponsors this week we
have me on these guys you have seen
these before me and these are some of
the most comfortable underwear they are
kissing the phone real quick they are
made of micro modo fabric modal she knew
no more ever ah twice as soft as cotton
nothing can really describe the field
manatees you kind of just have to try it
and then once you try you'll see why
they're the world's most comfortable if
you don't love your first pair of
Mandy's guys it's free
all right they have tons of styles and
like really awesome ones like this one
if mom would show you why don't you
display them doing wear them and show
them how it looks on the body yeah I can
yeah we'll probably probably get him
some underwear for for his undie run but
guys shipping is free in the US and
Canada and you can save up to $8 a pair
with me Andy subscription plan get the
subscription or single-payer get 20% off
your first order by going to meet undies
comm slash Jenna Julianne guys to go
check that out that's me on these comm
/g lane and our new sponsor of the week
BPI sports a supplement company with
incredibly high quality products one of
my favorites has been both the pump HD
which is a pre-workout and/or the BCA is
right here I love branched chain amino
acids for those of you who lift weights
and you constantly feel like your
muscles are sore and protein just ain't
doing it for you
BCAAs are great and having muscle
recovery faster and quicker absorb than
protein if you're new to BCA it's a very
very awesome thing in BPI makes an
incredible BCA one
the things I really like about bcc are
bbi's specific line of VCA is how it
dissolves in water you can throw it in
some water shake it up it's good it's
very easy to use very good amazing
flavors and it works well most of all
guys if you're into workout supplements
BPI sports calm has your supplement
needs we'll also link them in the
description and they have all these like
amazing flavors like what was this one
home the zoo watermelon cooler Oh
Jenna's gonna make a sound blue
raspberry Oh creepy G da wicked fruit
blasts Oh so check out obvi VI sports
guys and let us know what you think
links in the description right P was
Tori I don't know yeah Roxanne just hit
me with one gosh alright here we go it's
gonna be malicious
focus to that Oh so apparently Mok had a
pre I don't even know what to call it
alright but Julian used to dress as a
girl when he was a boy I'm ready buddy
but we're a bunch of dresses and he used
to sleepwalk what about your
sleepwalking stories oh you gotta tell
sleepwalking story did you put all the
toys in the oven
I think stepbrother is pretty much an
ice block it's like a hotel the car
alarm car alarm he like woke up one
night went in the bathroom turned on the
faucet and then went out to the car and
tried to get in like as a boy like a kid
I was completely so who knows I was
completely asleep okay I was on the top
bunk I was in a bump every bump outside
climbed down completely see what I
remember none of this
as I walked to the bathroom turned on
the sink left the bathroom that's all I
did in the bathroom walked outside the
front door of my house I was a 910
pregnant in 110 walked outside and tried
to get into my mom's minivan
open the door didn't open it was locked
car alarm goes off I go inside fall
asleep on the couch that whole thing
when I was at least you wake up because
well no
I don't remember any I never remembered
it even at the time when you guys told
me it happened I never remembered it
what are you doing trying you're crazy I
would have been horrified yeah terrified
if I was your mother I would have a
heart attack and die yeah um what she's
saying is how I used to dress up as
girls she was a dress-up of us up as
girls
she's tweeted pictures of that before it
was like marks early stages guys looked
so beautiful yes she would put dresses
on us and I wouldn't [ __ ] complain I
was just rocking that dress why should
why should I she's giving me free
clothing what else does she have
anything good in my Social section
gender class we talked a lot about like
gender fluidity and parents raising
their kids is gender neutral and like
dressing them in whatever they want not
not like socially constructing them to
be a boy or a girl and it's pretty
interesting how awesome how much of
environment plays to gender you know
yeah because we're born pretty similar
but then we just make boys and meet
girls yeah but that's like all yeah no
sugar you're gonna get so much gender
pressure once you grow up as it is to
not get it from your parents is pretty
liberating thing yeah it is so sure good
for parents that take all of that [ __ ]
off of their kid but then there's the
worry about the kids like being bullied
in school and stuff because it's it's
still like not accepted but at least
you're not putting them in pageants and
telling them and they have to be a
certain vision anywhere in the middle
bears problem so people are a better
place some little kids and parents
[ __ ] love that [ __ ] why do not go to
Marlins water come on Marlin used to
have imaginary friends
that's really cute what were their names
Michael oh okay so he had these
imaginary friends as a kid chase Jason
and Michael we're two of the main ones
they're countless no but Jason and
Michael were like two of his really like
favorite friends right Jason and Michael
we still linked up every every now
weirdest part as he gets to college and
his freshman year roommates are Jason
and Michael no swear to God
you just look around you're like let's
see I told you that I didn't think about
it oh my god okay so Marlon Marlon was
like its raw before he knew it but
someone came up to him and he was a kid
and was like it was everyone it was me
my mom
Roxane Marlon and we're just walking and
someone was like oh my goodness how did
you get your beautiful red hair and was
male he says I dyed it and he's like a
young ass kid oh [ __ ] who in your family
is red hair he says um I do god it's so
good for that one time somebody asked me
how I messed up my eye and I said oh it
was a black guy yeah don't tell that sir
in here and then they say what yeah and
I said so yeah so I don't know how you
got did you fall we were running around
you forgot into a doorknob yes like a
complete idiot he runs into a doorknob
and we're like it's right so we're
walking to my sister's dance class to
pick her up in my mom and uh he was like
an african-american security guy right
so he comes up to my mom he's like what
happened like well he's like hey yo what
happened your eyes you know son what's
going on and he meant to say it was a
black eye like it's a black eye like
it's my eyes black but he said it's a
black guy black and my mom's like
sitting there mortified like I said no
no tell him actually what happened oh
yeah my mom did it this no but it sounds
like he's making it up that's actually
how it went like this doing the biggest
trips okay I want you to seriously
answer these okay no more trolling what
is your favorite food let's get a little
lightening round here sushi okay sushi
what kind of sushi ahi tuna why'd you
have to say ahi why could you shoot said
tuna mmm no one thinks it's a different
type of tuna
see I don't like stuff you're trolling
still like in the sandwiches you know
like tuna salad is not to diversity
that's disgusting
okay it's not even the same they don't
even taste somewhere
we see if you engine were to fight each
other in a brotherly deathmatch heard
one hmm other weapons allowed what do
you think do you think it should be
weapons alone
no no weapons unarmed one arm you're
both completely unarmed if I can rub
Vaseline all over myself first I think I
would win okay I get out of the [ __ ]
iron bars but dry I think I I think I
get crushed dry I just put a Gyan you
here with us
no no DS um would you reckon constantly
smell dog poop or eat dog poop once hmm
eat dog poop once that's my [ __ ]
answer why get out of the way I don't
wanna smell dog poop remember you
eventually you'll eventually be immune
to it isn't it like really bad for you
what dog poop yeah I mean I don't think
it's good to eat any feces but like
there's a reason why we don't like the
taste and that's like poisonous for us
I'd rather read it one time and get over
it than smell poop village yeah awesome
I'll poop the rest of my life
do you Ness and yeah how do you to our
cross that [ __ ] up I put a protein shake
in [ __ ] Russia what to know what's
your favorite song hmm
well it changes every week well right
now what is it right now let's see
you've an interesting taste in music
yeah Marlon likes festivals you go to
Coachella like you like that stuff I
like hello by Adele okay I'm serious
no he can't no please I'm serious that's
all I've been listening to in case those
of you watching the two of them not
wondering where they get it from your
your dad is a sandal comedian yeah no he
what he absolutely master Oh nervous hey
if that's something we can't control
troll and them is so deeply ingrained I
used to steal my Joey
using a job as a stand-up comedian it's
bit yeah it's the same idea child is so
pick one copy infringement really
copyright copyright whatever's good
child that just looked up and said hey
dad what what what are thoughts like
what is that yeah no I don't want to do
that and I want to do that anymore is
that you it was right from the very
beginning
my dad had so many jokes about Marlon
when he did stand-up like like almost
all of his jokes really well all those
kids jokes like when he says my kids it
was always about my lunch hour all right
and what are these things happening in
my head I want to do that anymore so
it's kind of dark what I mean if you
took that in one way you're like yeah
don't want to [ __ ] think thoughts
anymore or you could take it in a way
that I was just super advanced in a
violent way yeah and I just would
appreciate life for what it is and not
thinking about everything else
appreciate some [ __ ] quiet in here
when because was the last time you ever
saw something or experienced something
without tying your thoughts to it it's
very difficult it's difficult you can't
just see something and accept it for
what it is they don't just have it be
there yeah you always have to tie some
sort of emotion memory whatever it is
and stigma you're always going to choose
something okay true like what was going
through your little tiny like prison
brain at that time where you were like I
don't want to have thoughts anymore
like I'm so disturbed by what's going on
in my brain yeah remember hazy you still
here yeah it's like half yeah maybe yeah
all right well did you guys ever use a
fight like daily fight and you guys ever
gotten in a fight trying to think uh
yeah like a real fight I tried beating
them up once
II didn't when was there once it was
after we went to Catalina for like a
week for our parents wedding and it was
like the whole family so we all had to
be on really good behavior and we had
fun we did a bunch of [ __ ] and just like
great family
time and I just had to be on my best
behavior the whole time so I couldn't
like fight back to Julian whatever he
would bug me so it just built up the
whole trip and right after we got off
the boat we like get back in the car on
the mainland and he like throws a
volleyball at my face for a soccer ball
hits me right in the face hey can we
kiss around here I didn't just take a
ball I'm sure I pissed you off
oh I have another one after this too so
um uh hits me right in the face and I
just go crazy because you know I like
broke my nose like a few years before
that and it was just very sensitive and
he it was just everything at once I just
tried to kill him like right right then
they're inside the car and my sister's
boyfriend at the time broke us up and
like just like held us apart like this
but yeah and the yeah that was the end
of that but you're lucky I could have
finished you you know what's crazy is
like I feel like every brother or you
know pair of brothers on earth has that
one story where it's like the younger
brother just [ __ ] had had it and went
to kill him you know and like just they
were they were it just is one of those
things like I I wasn't like a dick older
brother but older brother dynamic is
like you're you know you're on top all
the time and you must have just been
like that's it I had one of those with
my brother because we use so just like
because he's so much bigger than me like
smash me and like do [ __ ] food sit on
the couch with your feet against each
other you know and he's like the tallest
person in the world so he would just
smash me off of the push against the
side of the couch but like one time I
just so completely had with him I picked
up his lacrosse stick and baseball swung
it into his dick and is dead yeah I just
swear yourself is yeah I had it
that's [ __ ] yeah my mom was really mad
at me when we're gone my brother was
really really really mad at me but you
know sometimes you just had it and then
you snap that was it that was my day
just pick my house that my step-brother
bang yeah you did mmm I've heard that
sorry yeah heard that Starr just punch
him we were at another family thing it
always happens at family thing that's
what happens you're older
sibling just has it coming they know the
day is coming is there still [ __ ] I
actually landed a punch don't [ __ ]
hit me anymore man someday I'm going to
be able to hit you back yeah there hey
your day still coming yeah yeah you're
gonna get all your Vaseline ready for
that day yeah it's gonna be in your eyes
it's going to be everywhere um so you
you got what you gotta tell the story
now about when you have had it with me
in New York
oh that New York trip and your Marlo
hurry to the laptop
ok so yeah it was on my old laptop it
might still be there but we this is a
separate sorry but we were in New York
and with their it like as there is a lot
in New York there's those outdoor
stairwells you know on the side of
buildings and we were those higher scape
fire escapes sorry I'm not from those
two they are an outdoor stairwell it's
not funny
nobody uses them a tigress do we use
that we use are like plants and so we
climb out open window just walk at night
with our laptop cuz back then that's
like we shot things we didn't have
cameras so we were like yeah so we had
my laptop we're like yo this is crazy I
think I saw the video I should find I've
seen it I know you've seen it but I
think I still have it
but we'll heal those crazy we climb up
the [ __ ] fire escape so we can see
that like a weird angle of the Empire
State Building really it's right there
really freaking out probably being way
too loud but what he was talking about
is in New York we went to our
stepfamilies grandma's house to stay for
the night and it was six kids right mmm
it was all of us six kids one bedroom
one grandma
and snow and no parents cuz they're not
living it and they leave in the night
yeah they left for the night my mom and
my stepdad they went out for the night
and left us all there for hell Debray
close and it did we had like just every
tourist we have there's like little
[ __ ]
mini ass um Empire State no not under
state statute Liberty Liberty but it's
small it's like maybe a little taller
than this coffee cup but the base of it
is like [ __ ] marble it's like it's
like rock like a perfect handle it's a
perk you because you hold it by the top
and then the end is like it's like a
sledge
it was tiny okay I'm like a murder
weapon could essentially it could fit um
so I don't really remember what exactly
led to this book do you remember what I
do and you know okay what led to it um I
ended up hitting it with it in case
you're wondering well you were like we
were watching TV yeah you're pissed at
me already and you had like some snack
and you wouldn't give me some my snack
and you had it like in your mouth like
he's like sticking out you're like
pretzels or something after you I
grabbed it and like ate it I use that
not to get the stuff and liberty in your
face out even like like stet like
missing a step he grabs the statue and
just cracks me with it right in the
forehead God in my forehead like swelled
up with a golf ball it was just matter
was like Muhammad vs. Jose Aldo it was
just like a hematoma and my sister is
like probably 14 years old like trying
to figure out what to do not even how
long she's there with all of yeah she
was babysitting everyone and all the
other kids are just laughing at us
laughing at me he's trying to apologize
and my sister's just freaking out and my
step-brother is just like dying laughing
cuz he wasn't the one who did it
he's like so relieved that he's just
like chillin off the hook
oh my god are you is Marlon the marble
wearing me at ease right now yeah that
is amazing you can see it cuz son is the
wat Bobby you and me undies you and me
Andy um well if you think of any of the
stories we have to tell we're gonna see
what questions are yeah some questions
John you wanna look on the podcast
Twitter do you have your phone they
think think think think think if you
were given the chance to redo one thing
in your life what would that thing be to
read to it yeah mmm what was that
peachy coffin I don't know Timmy peachy
it's hard as I mention yeah what do you
guys think you guys have any regrets if
I were to redo one thing mm-hmm not
really I would just say no you know
really yeah
how do you sleep in the Hermit no means
she's either on your back so we were
done with that Mars on my side I like
sleeping on my side feels everyone be
done with that why how do you sleep at
night I can't sleep on my back I have to
sleep on my stomach
yeah yeah I get like my back hurts Oh
wakes up sore yeah I don't like it this
is a good question I want you to ask
answer this seriously do you like having
your brother on YouTube yeah well what
did why or why not well you loved it you
found a home you know it's it's a great
community did I really know about some
girl at a concert like come up to you
because not only was it uh it was at a
like a philanthropy event for my buddy
Hughes DJing deltac and yeah somebody
just recognized me because I was your
brother because you were in the vlog but
today somebody recognized Julian at
Starbucks that met him at the photo
Cedar Hills thing yeah I use it sounds
like a what's his name again
Bryan shout out to faster Bryan from
Starbucks and met me Woodland Hills he
lifts up that coffee P good he did
actually he didn't touch it he was
working the register but I bet he would
have Kermit me come here all right
Milan what's your what's your favorite
dog Shh it's a secret I think they're
asking of these three but it could be
puppy or honey
mm-hm well no I say he leaves it to this
day because he's obviously she's honey
hmm I know which one is the lie again
you don't have to answer it I have such
spiritual connections with all of them
you have different licenses of each one
of you yeah but I'd have to say okay
marble meet right under the mic I'd have
to say marbles really yeah mom you know
allons-y a model and took the longest to
to win his heart but his heart is just
so sweet he's a really special guy he's
once he trusts you and you're in his
little trust bubble he's like the most
fun sweet amazing little dog yeah yeah
mom I want to ask you before you go
probably college people out there do you
have any tips or life hacks the college
students being in costume what do you
what have you figured out because I have
one I'd like to share one but what are
your like things that you've learned and
you wish you knew I wish I did beginning
call yeah uh just like not to be scared
of anyone or anything I was always
worried about like what society said
about me and just like as I got to
college yeah we're just that much more
accepting and people really want to like
accept you for who you are and it's not
like bad to be who you are
let's go now people are always trying to
like when they go out or whatever put on
a face that they think they should be
you know instead of what are whatever
solution yeah instead of who they really
are
and it's good advice do you have any
specific like day-to-day things like how
to take naps or something because I have
them naturally and I have a good tip
like that let's hear it find a secret
bathroom that nobody knows about on
campus because it will make the biggest
difference like I found this bathroom I
know where it is I'll tell you later I'm
not gonna put on the podcast we had one
of those yeah it's a secret bathroom on
campus you either know about it because
of being in sports or somewhere
something that you had access that not a
lot of not everyone else had access to
and you secretly use that bathroom for
your entire time and it's just it's like
solace like no one can take that away
from you you don't have to go to the
crowded us bathrooms on campus anymore
you find that secret open to you what do
you have one too
yeah we had a secret bathroom got a
couple must know about those so nice
that is my advice it is pretty
life-saving should use the bathroom that
nobody else uses I still use it
Niccolo next to the gym no different one
I've two tips my tips are one for when
you're in college and one for when
you're out of college first tip is steal
a shopping cart
it's [ __ ] it will change your life
it's amazing College yes in college how
do you actually how would you use a shop
especially
if you live in a big city if you live in
a big city you steal a shopping cart now
all of a sudden you have like a way to
do your laundry and it's hysterical you
can build stuff out of it it's awesome
you can push your friends in it it's
really great the front numbers like more
fun times than you can even imagine will
come from you stealing a shopping cart
well you don't have to steal it forever
you can steal it for like a weekend and
then bring it back you don't have to
take it and the second one yeah borrow
it and the second one is for when you're
out of college is too if you still live
in the same area as your school and you
need the facilities for whatever reason
just keep going like I use for example I
used to need a printer I didn't have a
printer so I would just go into the
computer lab like in graduate school
because it was closer [ __ ] out or go to
the gym there's plenty of grown [ __ ]
people to go to our gym yeah it's a size
adjust because they never stop done
well yeah smile cuz no one asked them
not to or the library or things like
that if you look like you could still be
a college student or even if you don't
and you think you can get away with
getting in there just go in there and
still use it for like another year you
know what what that reminds me of I'll
end with this story right here in my
land I were in Vegas with my mom and we
were at this big convention where there
was like five different conventions
going on and we were there for my
sister's dance convention or whatever
but we had a bunch of free time so we
were walking around like exploring what
Expos were happening we found this it
was like a UFC Expo or something it was
like a fitness something cool that we
liked and we were using the freight
elevator because we were help hauling
the dance equipment but you we had
access to the floor that we were
supposed to be on so we walked onto this
Expo and we went over to the side we
were like okay it's like maybe $400 a
ticket to get in here and we're just in
here right now
how do we stay so we find this table and
we get chairs we sit up and we set at
this table like it's a booth and we just
look angry we're like dude look angry
like look pissed and no one's going to
ask a question if you look you're like
you're pissed off people are not going
to ask if you know that you should be
there to everyone else there we were
just sitting at the table just like
frustrated someone walked by with
a tag on maybe like no one cannot touch
yeah and we were just saying there for
the longest time that we just decided to
leave everybody just kept walking by
like she already guards everyone and
like that's what we're manatees like if
you act like you're supposed to be there
you know oh yeah you can go I think I
remember we were like pretending to chew
gum to make it look like we were like we
did have you only show attitude
you know what we were pretty we're
pretty innovative kids
he is a crap perception is reality it's
sure you're very crap that is true that
is true and I perceived that me and he's
is the most comfortable underwear in the
world so if you guys want to buy some go
to me Eddie's calm Jenna Julian Baba
where is it
I wear Marlon where is it get 20% off
your first order with that URL and then
go to BPI sports comm check out their
line of awesome supplements and let us
know how you like it thank you guys for
hanging out another week on the podcast
and thank you to Marlin for joining us
thanks violence tonight thanks for
hanging out I was a lot of fun ladies
ladies and the ladies fun is where can
the ladies 5 you what is your Twitter
account my will will link it below will
link all my own stuff below but super
gin super gin John Instagram is that
what it is no super gng you change it
sometimes you do not take the interns in
a bit
you do why it is Twitter is M so low 1 2
3
mm-hmm all right well thank you Marlon I
appreciate it yeah thanks so much for
hanging out on our podcast we'll see you
guys next week
on the Jenna and Julian podcast do you
think my guys good underwear mine well
Wow it's gonna follow up alright